but i heard that you performed at your  son's school was he is he at the age  like  where he thinks it's cool or is he kind  of like oh mom he was so you know it's  interesting  so sometimes he can take it or leave it  he was super proud that day of course  this wasn't this year because as i said  he wasn't there oh yeah there's a  picture of  my god i want to eat him yeah so  he loved it then though he was super  proud then and some days he's just like  yeah no  please just go on do not sing move along  that's all of our kids some days they're  so proud and then other days they tell  people that jonas is their favorite  voice coach and you're like  sure like fine i'm like sure yeah  jumanji was cool i guess  yep i'm still here just waiting for you  to subscribe  if you don't i'll be trapped in this box  forever help